AKSHAY: So hi, everybody.
Welcome to this Tech Talk.
So I'm here-- actually,
my name is Akshay.
I'm a UI designer at
Google, and I'm really
happy to announce that Ben
Von Wong has come here today
to speak to us.
Sometime last year I
discovered the photography
of Ben Von Wong.
I read about him, I checked out
his amazing epic photography,
and watched his YouTube
videos to learn what I could.
And then in December,
I thought I'd
contact Ben and get in touch
with him, never expecting
to actually hear a response.
But Ben responded in
about four minutes--
and I checked the email
just to make sure.
And this week actually he
came out to the [INAUDIBLE]--
he lives in Montreal-- came
out here and spent some time
at SmugMug.
He's been doing various shoots.
He was kind enough to invite
me on one of them this weekend.
And I discovered that not only
is he an epic photographer,
but he's also an epic guy.
So without further ado,
here's Ben Von Wong.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN VON WONG: Good
afternoon, everybody.
Thank you guys all
for taking time out
of your busy day to be here.
Super excited.
I don't think I ever
planned on coming
to speak at Google this trip,
so for me it's pretty huge.
And Google to me is a
white page with text box,
so this is pretty awesome.
Out of curiosity, just to
get a feel for who's actually
listening to me here
today, how many of you
guys are photographers?
OK, how many would
consider yourselves serious
photographers?
A little bit less,
but pretty good.
And who doesn't do
photography whatsoever?
OK, because everyone
has a phone, right?
So now you're all photographers.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
No, really cool.
Yeah, the reason is, my talk
is more or less centered
on to photography, but
the idea behind the talk
is really about inspiration.
So my idea behind
the talk is just
to come out here and talk
about the journey on,
I guess, how I've gotten
to where I am today,
and to share a couple stories
here and there along the way.
The way I've kind of
laid things out over here
is just-- I have the
introduction on why
I do photography
in the first place.
So what does it mean to
me, why is it important,
why I decided to become a
photographer, if you will.
I have a timeline where I talk
about the defining moments
in my career, and
how I built up,
basically, from buying my first
camera to ending up here today.
I deconstruct how these epic
photo shoots come together
by breaking down a couple
key elements on how I source
things, how I find people,
how I bring them together.
I go over failure
really quickly,
because I think that's
a subject, a topic,
that a lot of
people get stuck on.
And then last but not least-- I
keep the most exciting for last
so that nobody
leaves in the middle
my presentation, which is a
Photoshop deconstruction that
has some before and afters
that a lot of people like.
So along the way there are a
bunch of little question breaks
here and there, but if you
do want to interrupt me,
I'm super friendly and I
will answer your questions
as we go along.
Cool.
So today we're going to
start talking a little bit
about photography and
why it is something
that is really important to me.
And the reason I want
to kind of bring up
that initial subject is
because I think that people,
along the way as
you do photography,
the more you do it, you kind
of forget why you picked it up
in the first place.
People get a little bit
distracted with the business
side of things, about earning
money, they start shooting,
and then they get
bored along the way.
And for me, photography
is a whole bunch
of things that incidentally
are related, too,
but aren't entirely
what makes what it is.
So that sentence
doesn't make sense.
It's fine.
I'll move forward.
One of the reasons
why I like photography
is the ability to create
things that are epic.
I like to bring stories to life.
I think growing up as a kid,
I've always wanted-- you know,
I've always read
books-- fantasies--
and every kid wants to be
a knight in shining armor,
riding a horse whatever.
And suddenly I'm
in the situation
where I'm able to take these
visions that I had a kid
and bring them to life.
I'm able to find people,
connect with them,
and make something that really
shouldn't exist in reality
and just kind of bring it
into the present, which
is really, really amazing.
A shoot like this comes
together completely randomly.
I was actually sitting-- I
was actually just on Facebook
going through my messages, and
some dude from a medieval store
hits me up and says,
hey, I've seen your work.
I'd love to work on
something together.
You should come by our
store and check it out.
I said, sure, why not.
Went in, played dress
up for a couple hours.
And before we knew
it, we just started
talking about the possibility
of doing something together.
He had these amazing costumes.
And they said, you know,
we have about a two week
window where we
can do something.
We have all the stock in
from the new collection.
Would you like to do
something together?
And I said, well, I'm going to
head off to Europe really soon.
It didn't look that
feasible, but you know,
it was too cool of a
project to pass through.
So we had two weeks.
And before I left
the store that day,
we had already
locked on a location.
It was this medieval village.
And all I had to do was find
people to wear suits of armor.
So I went on Facebook,
hit it up, and said,
who wants to dress up as
medieval soldiers on a weekend?
And I ended up with
about 50 people.
And we ended up in this
really surreal situation
where we had these
guys just watching
these beautiful sketches
that I had made.
And this huge number
of people actually
ended up showing
up-- over 50 people
within the space of two weeks,
just to come and dress up
and have a great time.
You know, this was in Montreal.
It was right at spring, so
we had this crazy weather.
We had everything from
hail to rain to sun.
It made no sense.
But even though this
was a product that
was purely creative,
there was no money,
there was nothing involved,
all these people still got out.
And I think it's because
you almost bring back
a certain sense of nostalgia
to people where they can relive
something that they would
never have the chance
to live otherwise.
And this is really--
50 people in the middle
of this barn with fire,
with all these props,
and it's absolutely crazy.
Another reason why
I love photography
is the ability to create
things that are different.
This was a shot that
I did for a metal band
by the name of The Agonist,
and they reached out to me.
Once again, they only
had a two week deadline.
And they needed to come out
with shots where they just
wanted anything that
would be different,
anything that would
stand out, anything
that would make them a little
bit different from the crowd.
Because the minute you type
"metal band" in Google,
what do you find?
Well, you find this-- a group
of people with their arms
crossed against a solid black
background looking badass.
And you know, that's not fun.
Everyone does the same thing.
So when they said we
want something different,
we just started brainstorming.
What could we come up with?
And they said, a fight
scene would be fun.
So we said, why not?
And then we had to
find a location,
so I said loading dock, perhaps?
Loading dock on my studio.
And then we needed props.
So props-- in my case,
we had a minimal budget.
So we went to a dumpster, and we
just collected a bunch of crap
and just decorated this loading
dock, and did our photo shoot.
Took about one entire day.
At the end of the
day, we came out
with an image that
really was conceivably
one of the most iconic
images that they've ever had.
And the cool thing about
people that want you
because you're different,
because you stand out,
is that they're going to
want to hire you again
for the next time around.
So this time they
had a new singer,
and they wanted to introduce
a new singer into the group.
So we did the same thing.
We got them all
together, and they
wanted to figure out a way
to introduce the new singer
in a post-apocalyptic setting.
So we said, hey, why
not suspend the girl
and put in this factory kind
of setting and do a shoot?
So I started Googling for
a forge-- which we found--
and looking for ways to
suspend the girl, which we also
figured out.
And initially I want to do this
whole Photoshop deconstruction
where pieces of her legs
were coming off and really
cybernetic, but they
didn't want people
to think that their new
singer was handicapped.
So at the end of the day, she
needed all of her body parts,
and we suspended her,
and did all this stuff.
And there's actually going
to be a before and after.
I'll show you guys later.
Other reasons why
I love photography
is the adventures
that it brings,
the places that it brings you
that are completely unexpected.
This was a shot that I took
in Belgium for a retoucher
by the name of
Chester van Bommel.
And I met Chester
on the internet,
because I was looking at a
photographer whose work I quite
enjoy-- her name is
Viona Art-- and I noticed
on the bottom there was a
tiny little line that said,
retouched by Chester van Bommel.
And I'm like, hey,
this guy's pretty cool.
He's got some great stuff.
So I hit him up and said,
hey, we should work together.
And that conversation
just-- it blossomed.
We did a couple creative
products together.
And then the time came when I
was actually going to Europe,
and I said, you know, it
would be a really fun project
to kind of take a shot of you.
Show off what goes on in
the mind of a retoucher.
And so we started
brainstorming different ideas,
different concepts.
I ended up in Belgium.
I wanted to find a place that
was so grandiose that people
would automatically assume
it's Photoshopped but wasn't.
So I found an urban
explorer, who brought us
to this place,
which is, I think,
an abandoned stock exchange.
And I did everything my
parents told me not to do,
so that's meet up with
a stranger at 5 o'clock
in the morning in a random
parking lot for the first time,
and then go into a
manhole off on the street
in the middle of
another foreign country.
But then you end up in
this crazy situation,
this crazy location,
that you would never ever
have the chance to be in
unless I had a good excuse
to go out there.
Because I would never wake
up at 5 in the morning,
I'd never talk to a
stranger, I would never
go into a manhole to
end up in the place
if I wasn't doing photography.
So photography for me is
really about the experiences
that I get to enjoy
through photography.
Other things that I
love about photography
are the technical
challenges that it brings.
This was a shoot that I
did in a swimming pool.
And I wanted to come up with
a different idea with one
of my body painters.
And we came up with the
idea of suspending a camera
with a crane over a swimming
pool with some black lights
going over, because it
hadn't been done before.
So we ended up with this
crazy set, this whole group
of people, with our super
high tech secure setting,
here as you can see roped
together, MacGyvered together.
And the shoot came together.
I mean, it was probably one of
the most technically difficult
shoots that I had ever done.
Everything went
wrong in that shoot.
And you know, I came up with
all these crazy ideas initially
when sitting down with
this makeup artist.
We were kind of
trying to figure out
what hadn't been done before,
what would be really cool.
Then we thought black
lights, but black lights
had been done-- you know,
rave parties and all that.
Not super cool.
Then we wanted to sink the
black lights underwater
and do a shoot
there, and then we
didn't have the
technology to do it.
So finally we
settled for something
in the middle, which was suspend
the black lights over the water
and have these characters body
painted kind of popping out
through the surface.
And I had this whole
storyline planned out.
These are my
beautiful sketches--
which is why I'm a photographer
not an artist-- of dropping
a girl in the middle
of like a bed sheet.
We thought it'd
look like a flower.
It could symbolize birth.
And that didn't work out--
the girl almost drowned.
Well, she didn't almost drown.
We had safety around, but
it just didn't look good.
Then the next shoot
I wanted to do
was tie these two
people together
on the bottom of
the water to create
like a tree kind
of a looking thing.
That was supposed to symbolize
some kind of a union.
And that didn't work,
because they could hardly
swim on their own, let
alone being tied together.
So that wasn't going to happen.
So that went completely south.
Then I had this
other idea where I
wanted to create these little
like tadpole-looking things,
these three creatures,
which were just
supposed to symbolize
some form of life.
And this one kind of worked.
We took a rope, we dragged
all these three characters
across the swimming pool and
just get them enough momentum
so they're just floating along.
And it worked, but it
didn't look very good.
Then I had the first
breath of life,
which was these three characters
coming out of the water,
which is the one you just saw.
Then I had death,
which was supposed
to be the three of them lying
one on top of another, which
looked remarkably like
life, but just not as good.
So at the end of the day, I
had these elaborate concepts.
We spent about 12, 10 hours
shooting the entire thing.
A whole bunch of
things went wrong,
but I got one good
shot out of it.
And I suppose the moral of the
story is, I tried something.
I push hard to try and achieve
it, failed a bunch of things
along the way, but now I
know where my limitations lie
on what I can achieve,
and what I can't achieve,
and which parts to push,
and which parts to grow.
And I really enjoy those
technical challenges,
because if it were easy,
it wouldn't be worth doing.
Other things I love
about photography
are the inspirational
people that I
get to meet along the way.
I think photography
opens up windows,
and it's an avenue
of communication
that everybody has access to.
Doesn't matter if
you're rich, you're
poor-- everyone
can look at a photo
and understand
and appreciate it.
And this has opened up
countless doors for me,
just because I can just
reach out to people
and say, hey, I do photography.
I really like what you do.
Let's work on
something together.
And that's kind of my way
to connect with people.
So this is a shot of
the Underwater Realm.
And the Underwater
Realm is a group
of independent filmmakers.
Dave Reynolds-- the guy
sitting on the director's chair
underwater-- actually decided
to make a series of short films
underwater, and that's something
that hadn't been done before.
So they Kickstarted
I think $150,000.
And that guy's
like 26 years old,
retaining a whole crew
of like 50 to 100 people
for a two-year period--
all volunteers-- just
to make this series
of short films
that hadn't been done before.
So when I saw their Kickstarter
campaign, I was like, wow,
you are so cool.
I want get to know you.
I want to be a part
of your project.
I want to participate in this.
So I sent an email out.
Surprisingly, they
replied, and they said,
we'd love to work with
you, but you're in Montreal
and we're in London.
And at the time, I still
had an engineering job,
so it just didn't
seem very feasible.
But the connection had been
made, and that was great.
Fast forward eight
months down the line.
I was looking for inspirational
people across Europe to shoot.
And I reached out to them
again, and I said, hey,
would you like to be
a part of my project?
And this time around, it
just ended up working.
So I ended up in the middle
of the swimming pool,
working with these guys who,
for me, are super inspirational.
And I think those interactions
are so priceless and so
impossible to have otherwise.
You know, who goes through
these great lengths?
They had this videographer
who shoots for the BBC.
At the time, not many
underwater RED EPIC housings,
and he came,
volunteered his time,
just flew himself in just
to be a part of the project.
They built entire
sets underwater.
And I wasn't part of
this, because my shot was
under the trial phase, but
to see this come together
and to know that I actually
played a part in all of this
is absolutely phenomenal.
And it wouldn't have been
possible without photography.
And last but not least, the
reason why I love photography
is the ability to inspire
people, the ability
to connect with
people of all levels.
This was a shoot that I did,
and it was done in Florida.
We made all the piece
of the costumes.
We made the angel
wings, and all that.
And how it came
together was I put up
a photo of me breathing fire,
and this girl who is a Facebook
friend tagged one of her friends
in it, and she left a comment
and said, oh my
gosh, I'm never going
to be as good as this guy.
And I left the
comment, and I said,
oh, try putting your camera
to this and this setting.
And then she was like,
oh my gosh, he replied!
And she sent me like this
huge Facebook message,
just telling me that she'd
love for me to check out
her portfolio, that she
was a video student,
that she was also
a make-up artist.
And then it took me about
a week to reply to her,
but eventually when
we did reconnect,
I learned that she was also
a special effects artist,
she was off in Florida, and this
conversation just started out.
And she said-- it started off
as this dare-- and she said,
is there anything
that you've ever
wanted to shoot that you haven't
had the chance to shoot yet?
And then for some
reason, I said,
I've always wanted
to shoot angel wings.
I want someone to build
some angel wings for me.
And she said, if
you come to Florida,
I'll make the angel
wings for you.
And I said, if you make
the angel wings for me,
I'll fly myself to Florida.
And she said, OK, and
she started making them.
And I'm like aw, crap!
So I've got to buy a ticket now.
So I bought myself
a ticket to Florida.
And we didn't really know
what we're going to do.
And it all started off
with just this idea
that we're going to
shoot a fallen angel
in the middle of the forest.
And I got to the first day.
We went scouting, and we
saw this magical forest,
and I just came up
with these ideas on how
it would be nice to get the
concept even more elaborate.
And by the time of
the shoot itself,
it just scaled itself up.
We ended up, I think, with
seven models, full costumes
that we had built over
the space of a week.
These wings were actually built
with just some packing plastics
that we just strapped
to coat hangers,
and we dusted off with charcoal.
And it's just absolutely
cool and crazy to be
able to do something like this.
And on top of that, a company
called SmugMug-- actually based
out of Mountainview--
also noticed this project.
And they told me that since
I was in the United States,
they'd love to come down
and document my work,
because they thought it
was really inspirational
and they wanted to share this
vision with just the community.
So they flew their
own videographer down
to make this piece
over here that I
thought was
absolutely fantastic.
Being creative has just
become a way of life.
I don't think it
begins with the desire
to wake up in the morning
and say, today, I'm creative.
It just comes down to
today, I want to live,
I want to do what I love,
and so I'm going to go out
and I'm going to do that.
My name is Benjamin von
Wong, and I'm an artist.
I like to think of my
photography as something epic,
something larger than life.
It takes a vision
and exaggerates it,
so that you can't tell the
difference between what's real
and what's fake.
I take a concept, and I
transform it into reality.
I mean, I don't just
take the pictures.
I conceptualize, I design them,
I create them, I build them up.
It starts off with
a base concept,
it starts off with an
idea, and it slowly
builds up, based on
the constraints that
have available.
It's all about finding
solutions to make something that
is seemingly impossible
and making it
to something that is
better than reality.
I
Think that people
see photography
as clicking a button,
getting the lighting right,
getting the composition
right, but it's
so much more than that.
Being able to connect with
people is so important,
and it shows in
the final results.
If you understand
the story that you're
trying to tell,
then suddenly they
can translate that emotion,
making the image that much more
powerful.
I think that photos
can transport people
into another universe,
into another world,
and it becomes,
you know, a story.
And people try to figure it out.
They want to understand
what's going on,
and that just makes it magical.
I think that if you start
doing the things that you
love, and you start sharing
the things that you love, then
sooner or later, people
start hiring you to do things
that you love, for your
passion, for your vision,
for what makes you
unique, and because you're
the only person that can
do whatever that thing is
because you love it so much.
My name is Benjamin von
Wong, and I a creative.
So just think it's super cool
that a company would actually
be so interested in what
I do that they would
be willing to fly their own
person down to film this
and share it with the world.
And you meet people by
doing what you love,
by being passionate
about things.
And having the ability
to connect with people,
you meet the people that
believe in what you do too.
Incidentally, the reason
why I'm here today
is because SmugMug decided
to bring me in and just say,
hey, we really love what you
do, and we'd love to support it.
Come down.
We'll commission
some shoots for you.
We don't really know what
we want to shoot yet.
And we ended up suspending
some of their employees
off of a 40 story
building just yesterday,
with a camera dangling
nine feet off the ledge
on this massive C-stand.
We did a shoot so
that their employees
could come and attend,
off in the forest,
which is the one we
actually went to see,
where we had designers flying
in from LA, five models coming
in, just freezing their day
off in Sutro forest just to be
a part of all these projects.
And it's really, really
something amazing.
And it didn't really
always start off
with-- you don't
really start off
saying like, oh, I want
to be an inspiration.
I want to inspire people.
It actually began with me-- when
I started giving presentations
like these, I didn't
really know what
I was supposed to talk about.
So I went on Facebook and
I started asking for help.
And I want to ask people what
they thought about my work,
and have I made a difference,
have I contributed to them,
have I touched them in
any way, shape, or form?
And I got the predictable-- you
know, all the answers about how
technically they've
learned a bunch of things.
But then I came
across this one post
by the name of Tyler Grace.
And he said, I'm a
19-year-old teenager,
and I've lived half
my life in a hospital
thanks to a few
chronic illnesses.
I had no passion or drive
to do anything in life
at the beginning of last year.
But in about May or
June, I came across you,
and you are the one
person who really inspired
me to actually pick up
my camera and actually
be creative with it, rather than
just take happy snaps with it.
Photography has changed
my life, I'm now
in the process of
building a full-on photo
studio at my dad's
video production studio,
and I'm actually becoming a
known photographer around town.
That is all thanks
to you inspiring me
with your creativity
and awesome skill.
Even on the days when
I can't get out of bed
or I'm stuck at the hospital
or doctor's appointment,
I'm planning out my next shoot.
And this again is
all thanks to you.
You inspire me to keep
fighting and keep shooting.
Thank you so much.
And I think that was
like the first time
that someone had actually
said "you've changed my life"
like that.
What you're doing--
even if it had nothing
to do with what he was doing--
really made the difference.
And then suddenly that
sense of responsibility
of knowing that people
are looking up to me
and really paying attention
to what I was doing
became super relevant.
And I actually had the
chance to meet this guy just
in February, because
I was in Singapore
and his sister wrote
to me and said,
hey, Tyler's 21st
birthday is coming on,
and his dream is to meet you.
But we can't really
afford to fly you in,
so do you think you can make
a personalized video to him?
And I said, well,
I'm in Singapore,
and this is probably
the closest I'm ever
going to be to Australia.
I might as well just
fly myself down.
So I pack myself into a box,
and I showed up at his doorstep.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So I've just gotten
off a 10 hour or so
flight from Singapore
to [INAUDIBLE],
and we're off to
surprise Tyler Grace.
His 21st birthday's coming up,
and his wish was to meet me.
So we're going to be
granting a wish right now,
and that would involve
putting me in a box
and showing up on his
doorstep, and taking him
on a one-week adventure.
So let's see how it goes.
I want to strap a
GoPro onto my head
so that when I pop out
of this magical box
we can record Tyler's
astonished face.
[KNOCKING]
-Hi!
-Happy birthday!
[LAUGHTER]
-Can I give you a hug?
-Yeah.
-How you doing?
-Not too bad.
-What the hell?
-We decided to surprise you.
-That is awesome.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BEN VON WONG: It
was at the point
where basically what I
do right now is I travel,
and I go on these adventures,
and I meet people.
I'm this social media
content creator,
where I'm empowered
by the people
that I inspire through talks,
through conferences, that
actually finances my trips
to go to the next place
to keep shooting, to
keep doing things.
And I realized I could do
exactly what I normally
do-- I could just give a
conference, which would fund
my trip to Australia--
but in the process,
I could just drag along this
fan of mine for an adventure.
And he's got fibromyalgia,
super sick, bedridden guy.
And I didn't know
this at the time,
but he's probably one
of my hugest fans.
He's read like every single
one of my Facebook posts,
blog posts, everything.
He knew everything
about my life.
It was crazy.
And instead of just
showing up at his place,
I decided to just drag
him out on an adventure.
So we did a photo
shoot with him.
I took pictures of
him and his sister
like dragging him
through the mud.
He's from Australia, he's
never seen a wild kangaroo.
So we saw a wild kangaroo.
He'd never been to a rodeo.
We brought him to a rodeo.
He'd never been on a
canoes since he was seven.
And he wouldn't do that.
I put together a photo shoot
so that he could actually
attend it and see
what that was like.
So it was exactly what
I normally did, and I
did the behind the
scenes and everything,
but this time around, it
actually really, really made
an impact on this
one individual.
And I thought that was
a fascinating story.
So it's been a very,
very fun process,
this whole evolution
of photography.
So what I'm trying to
say at the end of the day
is that photography is not
just clicking the button.
For me, it's not about framing
a shot and clicking it.
That process just
happens to be incidental,
because it is the
vehicle for which I
can do all the things
that I love to do.
And I think that's
the same for everybody
who picks up a camera.
They don't pick it up because
they want to press that button.
They pick it up because they
want to showcase an emotion.
They want to transport
people to a place.
They want to capture beauty
in some way, shape, or form.
They want to show something
that doesn't exist.
They want to create
something new.
So photography has reasons.
There's a reason why
you love photography
and why it's special
to you, and I
think it's always
important to remember
what those reasons are.
Questions?
You guys are terrified of me.
Or you're sleeping.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So what clicked so you
turned from the engineering job
to the photography job?
What was it inside of you
that made that happen?
BEN VON WONG: I got bored
of engineering, and I quit.
And then incidentally, I became
a photographer by default,
because that was the
only thing I was doing.
It wasn't really planned.
I got bored of engineering.
But I actually go over
that in the next part
where I can talk
about the timeline.
Cool?
So I'll move forward.
So I have this quote
from Ernest Hemingway,
and it says, "It is good to
have an end to journey towards,
but it is the journey
that matters in the end."
and I think that just a
really important quote,
because at the end of the
day, I think something
that I realized along the way is
that you spend a lot more time
trying to get to
somewhere than you
do when actually
spending time there.
And it's kind of funny, because
you set these really lofty
goals, and then
suddenly you reach them.
And then you need to
set something else,
because there's nothing
else to do about it,
because you've
already achieved it.
And it gets really boring.
And if anything--
in my case, I've
found it disappointing
once I've achieved it,
because I'm like that's it?
I've gotten there already, then
just try to keep aiming higher.
So I think it's always
really important
to realize what you've
achieved up to now,
where it's brought
you, and it just
makes life a lot more
interesting along the way
if you can just
reach these points.
Just to give you guys a quick
example, I think two days ago,
I had a day off, and I
spontaneously decided to hop
in the car and drive
to the Apple campus,
where incidentally got kicked
out because it was a Sunday.
And we snuck in when
the door was open.
I just sat on top
of the Apple sign
and took a photo on Instagram,
and I was just so happy,
because I was just
in Apple campus.
And I've read the
biographies of Steve Jobs,
and I've seen all that stuff.
Or even being here today,
just these little moments
in time, these
slices of time, just
to be like, what
am I doing here?
How did I get here?
This is crazy.
It's just really, really fun
to sit back and appreciate
what you've gotten.
And keeping that
in mind, I'm going
to talk about the process on how
this Von Wong moniker actually
came to be, like how did
I become this character?
By the way, for those of
you who are wondering,
Von Wong is not my real name.
It doesn't exist.
Von is German.
"Von" means "from."
So when I was inventing
a name-- or actually,
the first thing you
do when you start
looking for your own website
is you put your own name
into Google.
And the first name
that came up was
Benjamin Wong, which
is my real name,
was another photographer that
did weddings off in Toronto.
I was like, hell no.
That's not gonna work.
So I decided to invent something
that would be a little bit more
exciting and marketable.
And then "from" in German,
from the family of Wong,
just seemed kind
of catchy and cute.
It actually sounded
really corny at the time,
but now it sounds pretty cool.
I've got people calling me
Mr. Von, which is hilarious.
[LAUGHTER]
But anyway, so the
birth of Von Wong.
And it didn't all start
off like-- you know,
I don't have one of those
crazy awesome stories
that people got a camera
at the age of three
by their grandfather,
and their eyes
lit up when they saw
the first frame happen.
My story is a little
bit more mundane.
I was working in a mine in
Winnemucca, Nevada, in 2007.
And around this
timeframe-- you can
see the nice little
timestamp on the bottom--
this girl breaks up with me.
And I decide that, if
I don't find something
to do to keep myself busy
in this small town of 10,000
people with two
Chinese people, I'm
going to go absolutely crazy.
So I decided that,
why not go out there
and take pictures of the stars?
Stars are pretty.
So I went to Walmart,
bought a point and shoot,
tried to take a
picture of the stars.
Wasn't good enough.
Returned it and bought
the bigger camera,
the more expensive one.
And it was also not good
enough, so I returned that.
And I had to drive to the next
city over to go buy a DSLR.
And I remember going in
there, and I just didn't even
know what to do with it.
I just kind of said,
how do you turn it on?
Because you have to
look in the viewfinder.
So the guy said, what you want?
I said just get me any
camera that's about $800.
And he kidded me
with a Pentax K100D.
Then I took that,
went to Starbucks,
sat down, read the manual.
And then by that evening, I just
drove out, slept in the car,
and I took my first
photo of the stars, which
you can see this fantastic
masterpiece over here.
Entirely grainy,
nothing spectacular,
but I was really, really happy.
I had my photograph of stars.
And this was the
first photo that I
guess that I ever
successfully took.
And probably one of the
last-- I haven't really
taken pictures of stars since.
But by that point,
I had a camera,
and it became my
travel companion.
I brought it around
everywhere, and I
became that really
annoying Asian guy
with a camera that
brings it to everything.
So every party, every
event, every time
I was out on the street,
I had this camera.
I joined every single
photo club that I could.
And then I made a new girlfriend
who was also a photographer,
and that whole thing
just started building up.
And as the way things
go, the more you shoot,
eventually you start
meeting people.
And one of my friends was
actually an event photographer,
and he couldn't make
it to an event anymore.
They had dropped the
rates a little bit.
And he said, hey, I can't
make it to this event.
They don't pay that well.
It's like about
$200 for five hours.
There'll be pretty
girls and free alcohol.
Do you want to help me cover it?
And I said, sure, no problem.
So I went and I shot
this first event.
And I remember I rented a
monopod so that my camera would
look bigger and
more professional.
And I did my first shoot.
And this is the first
time that I had actually
gotten paid to do photography.
And it really clicked
something in my mind,
which was the first
time that I had actually
gotten paid to do something
that I enjoyed to do.
Now, usually you pay money to
do things that you like to do.
But this time, I was getting
paid to have a good time,
to go drink and take pictures
and do all this stuff
and meet people.
It was absolutely fantastic.
So I used that as an excuse
to buy a whole bunch of gear.
Thankfully, I was an
engineer, so buying gear
wasn't a problem.
Went out there, bought some
more gear, started shooting.
And I was shooting like
three, four times a week.
And I shot everything,
it didn't really matter.
I just brought my camera out.
I was shooting bands,
I was shooting events,
I was shooting protests.
I was just getting myself into
all sorts of weird situations.
And photography was just
that companion of mine.
And it didn't just
stop at events.
It also extended-- you do just
a little bit of everything.
So in my case, I shot a
little bit of portraits,
I shot some engagement things,
I tried my hat at levitation.
Even let a little
bit of Photoshop
in-- you can see the fantastic
smoky effect over there
on the left.
It's just all part of that
process of just growing.
But I was getting out
there and I was shooting,
and then invariably when
you start shooting enough,
you start getting a
little bit better.
You start shooting
bigger events.
Things start going really well.
You fall into weddings,
because everyone ends up
shooting weddings at one point
in their time in the photo
career.
And the photos are actually
getting quite decent,
and business was going
really, really well.
But then what happened was
I got into another break-up.
So break-ups are
these fantastic events
in my life where you question
every single thing that happens
to you, and you
wonder why you're
in these weird situations.
And then in my case, I
came to the realization
that I had two jobs at the
time-- I had engineering
and I had photography.
And that wasn't what I had
originally set out to do.
I had engineering as
a job, and photography
was supposed to
be the fun thing.
But at this point, it
had become two really
time consuming,
exhausting activities.
And I kind of did
the calculations.
I said, well, I
didn't need the money,
so this wasn't what I
wanted to do in photography,
so why was I doing it?
So I just dropped the
entire event set of things,
bought some new
equipment, some new studio
flashes, and tossed
myself into this project--
the 365 project-- which is to
take one photo a day every day
for 365 days.
I failed.
365 days is a long time.
So incidentally, I only
got about 100 days in.
But through that
process, I really
got the chance to
grow as an artist.
Every single day, I had
to come up with new ideas,
so eventually I
ran out of models
that I could actually collect
within the timeframe necessary,
so I started learning a lot
of Photoshop to compensate.
It was just this really
good growth process
of just growing and
growing and growing.
And when I decided
to quit, it was
because I wasn't able to
sustain this many photo shoots.
And I hit 100 days,
and I told myself
that, well, now that
I have more time,
I might as well do these
more elaborate shoots,
start collaborating with
different individuals,
taking more time to
go to cooler places.
And that's where I
think my style started
to get shaped a little bit more.
You see we have me exploring
some abandoned building,
dressing people up,
going to studios,
suspending people together.
There's actually a chair there.
Just by Photoshopping it
and rotating the foot,
you have this beautiful
levitation effect.
And, you know, breaking
into abandoned places
with guys with guns.
Always a good idea.
Doing everything from school
project-- Shades of Gray
was a student project
from Concordia.
I also started working
with body-painters.
So all the weird-- all
the eclectic things.
I started experimenting
with special effects.
We had a smoke machine
in the center image,
and the one completely
on the right
is one where we-- I was
shooting on a bridge,
I flipped the camera upside-down
super close to the water.
We tossed dry ice into
the lake, and then
bam, we had this crazy
super smoky effect.
It was getting
really, really cool.
And then as the
shoots went on, they
started getting a little
bit more elaborate,
I started getting more
people, experimenting more
in Photoshop,
played with zombies.
Everyone plays zombies.
Just like what weddings--
it's a recurrent theme.
And I had some zombies.
I started playing with
a little bit of fire.
And you know, the
shoots just start
getting bigger and
bigger and bigger,
and then eventually
I just decided
to quit my job as an engineer.
So there are a couple
actual points in time
that led to me
becoming this Von Wong,
and I'm going to try
to break them down
into these little categories.
And the first kind of moment
that defined my career
was in 2008.
And 2008 was the discovery
of something magical
called speedlights.
So at the time, I had a
D300, I had an 18 and 200,
and I had an SB 900 thing.
And I was like,
OK, this is great.
I don't need anything more.
We're going to be set
for the rest of my life.
It does everything.
And I was wrong.
I went to this free event
hosted by the Strobist community
in Montreal.
And you know what
happens in these events.
There's like a semicircle of
photographers, and one person
there, and everyone's
taking the same photo
from a slightly different angle.
But this time around,
someone just came up to me,
and they handed me like
a little trigger dongle,
and I just slapped that onto
my camera and took a picture.
And then suddenly,
my photo in my hand
was completely different
from what everyone else had.
I like to be different.
I think it's because I'm Asian.
I have this complex I
need to be different.
So I just said, what we
really need-- this is amazing.
I get to tell
stories with this, I
can create things
that are different,
I can start getting
a lot more creative.
And then that's when really
my style went from stuff
like this-- which is general,
really compositional based,
these photo ops of
friends of friends
going to interesting
places, taking
all the different like oddball
poses-- to finally starting
to get a lot more creative,
a lot more experimental.
Now, the photos are by no
means anything too fantastical,
but they really opened up
this vessel for creativity.
And since I started doing these
lighting set-ups and these more
elaborate looks and
dos, then Photoshop also
kind of came into place.
So it was this vessel learning,
because it just opened up
this world possibilities to me.
In 201o-- so between 2008,
2010, pretty much the same thing
happened.
I kept shooting.
I got better.
My shoots got a little bit
more elaborate, like I said.
But what really
changed in 2010 was
that I did a shoot
where I actually
recorded a
behind-the-scene video.
So you can see the photos.
They're pretty cool, but
not necessarily any cooler
than any of the other
images that I was taking.
It was done with flour.
We went into a studio.
We tossed flour
all over the place
and made a huge mess of it.
It was great.
And the one difference, though,
is that this time around, I
had a behind the scene
videographer come in.
And actually it was my
ex-girlfriend at the time--
my girlfriend the time--
who really, really wanted
me to start doing
behind-the-scene videos.
And I remember arguing
with her and saying,
why would anyone want
to see what I do you?
It would be boring.
There's no reason for it.
And she really argued
hard against it.
So eventually went to Future
Shop, bought a camera,
and returned it
every other week just
to record these video
footages, and started
making these
behind-the-scene videos.
And what happened
was the same photo,
the same shoots that I had spent
the same amount of time that
were just as cool, because they
had a behind-the-scene video
suddenly meant that they
were getting picked up
by all of these up
and coming blogs.
So like DIY photography,
Fstoppers, and all this stuff.
So those same photos that
I was creating suddenly
had gained a lot more
traction on the internet.
So I told myself
that from this point
forward, if ever I
did a photo shoot,
I'd have to have a
behind-the-scene scene video,
because the same images
were getting seen more.
And if we don't create
to share, then why do you
bother creating
in the first place
if no one's going
to see it, right?
That was a huge thing for me.
And then we hit 2012.
So between 2010, 2012,
not much happened.
I just kept shooting.
I kept videoing.
My internet popularity
started to grow.
But 2012 was when I decided
to quit my job as an engineer.
So as I said, I
woke up one morning,
and it was after three and
a half years of engineering.
I had kind of passed
that little threshold
that takes you from junior
engineer to engineer.
And that's a little chapter, so
I'm supposed to get a pay jump,
and all that good stuff.
And then I figure that,
you know, what's next?
If I keep going
this, and another 10
years of engineering, I can keep
climbing the food chain slowly.
But it wasn't what
I wanted to do.
So I didn't need money.
I had put money away in savings.
I was still living
with my parents.
So all this stuff-- there
was no reason for me
to keep going in engineering.
So I made up my mind,
I think, in the space
of 10 minutes waking up in
the morning that I'm done.
I'm going to quit.
The decision to
convince my parents
was a little bit harder,
though, since they
weren't totally
stoked about the idea.
And I kind of
tricked them and said
that I was going to do an MBA.
And I fully had the
intention of doing an MBA,
until I started sitting
down and realizing
that for two years of
my life, I was going
to have to shove everything
else away, focus on this MBA,
take all my savings, toss it
into this educational program,
get out with nothing-- except
a nice little piece of paper.
So I renegotiated the
terms of our agreement.
I ended up just doing a GMAT.
And then I could still go
back to school if I needed to.
It's my Plan C,
if ever I need to.
And told my parents I
was going to just try
to figure the
photography thing out.
And so what happened when I quit
my job was that I didn't know
what I wanted to do, because
there's no three year plan,
there was no five year
plan, there was no studio,
there was nothing, so
I decided to go travel.
So when I traveled,
the first thing I did
was travel to the
most exotic place
that I could afford to go
to, that I knew somebody at.
That happened to be Israel.
So I crash on this guy's sofa.
And his name is Udi.
He owned a blog called
DIY Photography,
and it was the first
time that I actually
met somebody that
lived off the internet.
He had a job at Texas
Instruments Systems engineer.
And he was earning more money
from his blog part time,
so he decided to quit
and do that full time.
And I was like, oh hey,
this is pretty interesting.
How do you do it?
He was like, well, you
need to have a blog.
I'm like, oh.
You've got to have
a YouTube channel.
I'm like, oh.
So I just started
realizing all these things
that I needed in order
to keep progressing,
at least to transform something
into sustainable business
model.
So I finish that trip, I came
back home, and it was great,
and I was like, OK, I
want to keep traveling.
But I had a problem.
I didn't have any money.
So what did I do?
Well, I decided to ask
people for money instead.
Right?
So I did a crowdfunding project.
By this time, I already had
a pretty decent influence
on the internet.
I'd done my
behind-the-scene videos,
I had been teaching
people for free.
I didn't have a
blog to consolidate
all the information,
but it was out there.
And I reached out,
and I asked people
if they would support this tour
of mine to go through Europe.
And surprisingly, I
put up a 5,000 thing,
and I got $12,000 back
in return of people
that believed in me enough
to support these projects.
And then I went on this trip.
And then suddenly
I went from being
a Montreal-based
photographer to being
a guy who had photos of
pyrotechnicians off in France.
I had some mask
designers off in Spain.
This shot-- that
was done in London.
I have this one in Belgium.
This was the National Slovak
Theater off in Slovakia.
This shot of a paraplegic
Olympic athlete off in England
also.
And I have this shoot over
here of a band off in Belgium.
So now by default,
it didn't matter
that I wasn't paid
for any of this stuff.
I just suddenly became this
international photographer.
And then these stories all
gave me that cohesive storyline
to start building
a YouTube channel,
to start consolidating all of
my viewership, all of my fans.
It also give an
excuse to make a blog,
because I had something
to talk about.
The biggest problem with
a blog is figuring out
what you want to talk about.
And it just really,
really started
bringing the whole
thing together.
So that was really what
2012 was about for me.
And I fall into 2013, and I
had reached this really, really
interesting point in my
life, where by that time
I had 29,000 fans on Facebook,
16,000 subscribers on YouTube,
30,000 monthly
views on my blog, I
was doing international
workshops and conferences,
and I was traveling about
six months of the year.
And you're like,
all right, well,
where do you go from here?
On top of that, I had
actually collaborated
with a whole bunch of
different companies.
I'd been published in all
sorts of different places.
And I was like, I don't
really know what else to do.
I want more
commercial contracts,
but you can't just make your
own commercial contracts.
Someone needs to hire you.
And in my case, I
didn't want to start
bending who I was to start
attracting these clients.
And I was stuck in this
rut of not really knowing
where I wanted to go
from that point forward.
And it just so happens
that, because I was just
waiting for something
to happen, I guess,
this girl by the name of
Nicole writes an email
to my agent out of nowhere.
Basically it's this
50-year-old lady
who is diagnosed with
a terminal illness.
And she'd never done a
photo shoot in her life,
and she really wanted to do
a creative photo shoot that
would represent who she
was so that at her funeral,
she would have a photo that
she had chosen, that she had
designed, to
showcase who she was.
So my agent forwarded me
this email, and I saw it,
and I said, hey, yeah.
Definitely.
Let's do this.
So I gave her a
call that same day.
She wasn't even
expecting a response,
and it was absolutely
crazy for her.
And we took her on an adventure.
We took her out to do photos.
We got bookshelves-- we
went to Salvation Army,
got bookshelves,
books, typewriters.
We found a tree.
I went and took her
location scouting.
Found hair, makeup,
the whole nine yards
organized within
a two week period.
And took for her
some crazy images
that she just never really
had the chance to have before.
And what was absolutely
crazy about this experience
is that my photos up
to now had really just
been about doing
these cool adventures
that I would share with people.
But they had never
really touched
someone-- touched them before.
Like, the photos
themselves had never
really mattered
to an individual.
So for me, to have images
that really meant something
to somebody was really, really,
really, really crazy for me.
And that really got me thinking.
And I told myself,
you know what?
I really need to do
more projects like this.
This stuff is fantastic.
But you now, you can't
really wait for someone
to send you a message saying
that they're terminally ill
and they need photos.
So I decided to reach out to
the Make-a-Wish Foundation.
I tried Make-a-Wish USA, I
tried Make-a-Wish Canada.
I reached out to them,
told them what I did,
and that I'd love
to get involved.
And we talked.
It went great, and
nothing happened.
So I just ended up
in this situation
where my mind frame was set on
doing more products like this.
I didn't know how they
were going to come about,
but I was kind of
working towards it.
And that's where the idea
of going to visit Tyler off
in Australia came forth.
And additionally,
there's this project
that actually just
landed on my doorstep.
This little girl--
I got an email
from one of my contacts,
a writer at PetaPixel.
So the full story is,
there's this father
off in South Carolina who
has this little daughter
with a degenerative
brain disease.
She's four years old.
And basically right
now, she's normal.
She runs, she talks, she
laughs, just like any other kid.
But over the next
three to four years,
she's going to slowly stop
walking, stop talking,
stop everything, and
just basically die
around her teenage years.
And there's a cure
that's available,
but what's missing
right now is money
to fund the clinical trial.
And he had Googled online
"how to make a viral video,"
because at that
point they had raised
$43,000 on their GoFundMe
campaign after nine months,
and they didn't really
know what to do.
And they had three
months left to raise
the next-- what
was it-- $950,000.
And had no idea how they
were going to do it.
So they went to Google.
They searched, they
ended up on the website
of some girl called Karen Chang,
who had written an article "How
to Make a Viral
Video-- 10 steps."
And he just read it
and he was like, this
doesn't mean anything to me.
I can't do this.
I'm just a normal guy
trying to help my daughter.
And he writes her an email
saying, hey, I need help.
She had seen my video that
I had made for Nicole,
so she reached out to the
editor of the blogger that
had featured me, saying, do
you know any videographers
that might be interested
in participating?
He sent an email out
to a bunch of people.
And I got this email between
Singapore and Malaysia
on my phone.
And I was sitting on the plane
just getting ready to take off.
They said, well, we
need a million dollars.
We need a viral video.
We have three months to do it.
And I was like, seems
like a hard project.
I'm down.
So I wrote back a message, and
I said-- within 10 minutes,
I wrote back and I said, I'm
not the best videographer
out there.
Actually, I'm more
of a photographer.
But if you guys are
willing to have me,
I have 10 days free next month.
I'll fly myself over, and
help you guys make a video.
And there's only two people
that replied to that email--
and it was sent out to 50,
100 people-- and that was me
and SmugMug that replied three
days later, which I thought
was absolutely crazy.
So this entire
project went along.
I flew myself over,
helped to make a video so
that their little
girl wouldn't end up
looking like the
other one on the side.
And the video-- I'd like
to play it really quickly.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Cara always wanted a daughter.
We'd a couple miscarriages,
and finally, we get very lucky
and have Eliza.
-I would describe Eliza as
a very affectionate child.
Happy, very active,
and the little girl
that kind of keeps
you on your toes.
-It was just great for two
and a half, three years.
I would say we had the
perfect-- just the perfect life.
I didn't go to the meeting when
the diagnosis was received.
I wasn't even at that.
It was another just
check it off the list
to make sure that this
isn't what-- I didn't even
know what the meeting was.
I didn't even there was a
genetics meeting happening,
honestly.
-And they just
said, you know, I'm
not gonna beat around the bush.
I'll just tell you like it is.
She's got Sanfilippo Syndrome.
And having heard
about the syndrome
before through my
medical training, I mean,
I just-- that sinking,
pit of your stomach,
like this is really bad.
This is a really bad.
-You know where it's headed.
It's headed towards suffering.
It's headed towards
pain for her.
And as a father, you want to be
able to protect your children.
-If the money
doesn't come in time,
she'll stop speaking
within the next six months.
She will stop walking
withing the next two years.
Stop being able to feed
herself in the next three
to four years.
She will develop seizures
and movement disorders,
experience a lot of
pain and suffering.
And then she'll die.
-The donations that
come in are going
to fund this clinical
trial, and fund
a chance at life for Eliza.
I mean that is the
hope we hold onto.
-Hope is a nice word,
but we need action.
We don't just have hope.
There is something
very real that
exists that, with enough
money, will happen,
and will happen in time for
our Eliza and other kids.
-I mean, it is so close.
We're just so close to
this being done, and being
put in children.
It's going to be hit or miss.
-It's not a question of, you
know, if this can happen.
This will happen.
-Please share.
Please share.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BEN VON WONG: So coming
up with a video that
was able to explain this
really complicated syndrome
within a three
minute period to hold
the attention of the internet
was a huge challenge.
And actually, putting
together this interview
was really, really stressful,
because you're there,
listening to these interviews,
over and over, of the two
parents just talking about
how hard it was for them
to learn this news,
over and over.
And knowing that the
results of these videos
were directly going to
impact the life of this child
wasn't really something I
had considered at the time.
I just thought it was going
to be a cool challenge,
and then I realized
after that, I
was literally like that
this video represented
the one hope they had
of actually successfully
or unsuccessfully funding
the entire project.
And thankfully
the video actually
picked up quite nicely.
And within a three month period,
we had actually hit $1 million.
And right now, they're
off and their campaign's
still going on.
They have another
$800,000 to go.
But now the deadline's been
push back up to October.
And it's this really
crazy situation
where they're doing
all of this work,
they're trying to raise
all of this money,
and they don't even
know if their child is
going to be selected
for the trial.
So this really this chance to
cure this incurable disease
that everyone's been putting
a lot of effort into.
And it's just
really magical to be
a part of a process
like this, and being
able to leverage social
media and all this content,
and all these things that I've
done over my career, I suppose,
has been absolutely crazy.
I launched a site with
SmugMug, just photographers
donating their prints to sell
their prints to their fans
and followers.
And we've managed to raise
$28,000 through that alone.
So there's all these
different-- I don't know,
the internet is
this amazing place.
And photography isn't just
limited to taking pictures,
but it is so much
larger than that.
It is something that you can
reach out and connect people
to.
And it's been really, really
amazing to see all of this,
and it's something
that, you know,
I decided that I really want to
start being more of a part of.
So if we were to break down the
different phases in photography
in my career, we have 2008,
which is about learning.
We have 2010, which is
about sharing, 2012,
which is about dreaming, and
2013, which is about evolving.
And these are
really four phases,
I think, in a person's
career that-- these
are things that are
always going to come back.
You never want to stop learning.
You never want to stop sharing.
You never want to stop dreaming.
And you always want
to keep evolving,
because things change as you go.
And if you spend too
long going on a path
and start questioning
why you're doing it,
it's time to re-evaluate
why you're doing everything,
and figure out where you
want to go from there.
So questions?
You guys are all sleeping.
One!
AUDIENCE: What
happened to the child?
BEN VON WONG: Well, she's--
what happened to the child?
She's still there.
Right now, they've been
featured on everything,
from NBC to the Today Show.
It's gone around, and
now we're still waiting.
I just did this
three months ago.
This is current right now,
and the question is, will they
make enough money
for October, and then
the next question
is, will she even
be selected, which is
outside of our control.
Actually, you can
use the microphone.
AUDIENCE: You said that
you were considering
doing works like the
one you described,
and like the one, the video.
So are you managing
to sell these projects
and to make money out of
it, out of these people?
Are you getting
progress in that?
BEN VON WONG: Well,
I do occasionally
get hired to take photos from
time to time, which is great.
I can't say that I have been the
pinnacle of commercial success,
but it also hasn't been
what has driven me.
If anything, what's
driving me is the idea
to create content that
is social media friendly
that will get my name
out there, because I
think the money will
come, sooner or later.
And right now I'm in the stage
where I'm travelling eight,
ten months out of the year.
I'm meeting people
all over the place.
I'm doing things that nobody's
ever done before-- I mean,
I just did a shoot in
a shipwreck in Bali,
25 to 30 meters
underwater-- that no one
would hire me to do right now.
But I can do it, and I
did it, and it's gone out,
and it's gotten a
lot of attention.
And all these things, all these
projects that I'm building
will build up eventually
to a commercial career.
But once I get there, and I
have a house and I have a car
and I have a studio, I
can't be crazy any more.
I can't go around.
So I'm not really in any
rush to get to that point.
And I do have an agent, and
she's there to make sure
that all the pieces
are lined up properly.
I have a bunch of
corporate sponsorships
of people who give me
equipment, support what I do,
and enable me to
keep going forward.
So all the pieces are in place.
When the commercial
gigs come in, I do them,
and they're fine.
But it's not the
focus right now.
Right now, my focus has
really been creating things,
doing things that I love,
getting out there, and making
awesome stuff.
AUDIENCE: So one thing I've
picked up through everything
that you said is that pretty
much everything you've done
is with the involvement,
with the help,
with the input of other people.
And in particular,
it sounds like a lot
of that has been
from social media,
like social media is
the be all, the end all,
the end unto itself
kind of thing.
I'm wondering if that's
a fair assessment,
if I'm picking up things
correctly from you.
If you started out
basically establishing
your online presence, and it
just kind of went from there,
or if there's been
more to it than that,
if there's been a little bit
more of traditional outreach,
so to speak.
BEN VON WONG: I think
growing up as a kid,
I've always been somewhat
of an attention whore.
Yeah-- do I keep talking?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
BEN VON WONG: Oh, OK.
Yeah, so growing up,
I've always been somewhat
of an attention whore.
And then I've never been
really great at anything.
I've done a whole bunch of
things-- I've played violin,
I've done martial arts, I've
done dancing and everything--
but I've never been
great at anything.
I've never been really
good at anything.
And then suddenly
with photography,
I started being
half-decent at something
that I could then share
with people, that I would
get some great
feedback from, and I
could interact with people.
So I think social media-- like
without social media, if we're
still on film, I probably
wouldn't take pictures.
I don't have the patience
to go in a darkroom
and lock myself in a hole
and come up with pictures
that a couple people
are going to see.
So I wouldn't be able to
do the projects that I do,
I wouldn't be able to
travel the way I travel,
I wouldn't be able to meet
the people I would meet.
So yeah, I think that's
definitely a fair assessment
to say that internet's
changed the world.
It's shaped my world.
AUDIENCE: In the movies, we have
a director, and we have a DP.
You don't.
You're directing and
doing photography?
How do you manage such
a large crew and actors,
many times as those actors are
models are not professional,
so they're even more
demanding to work with
and to try to get
your vision out of?
BEN VON WONG: I think the
answer to that question
is there's not really
any good answer to it.
The answer is I just do it.
At the end of the day,
I don't have a team.
I source my team of
freelancers whenever
it's needed, the idea being
that if you need someone,
you just reach out to them.
And of course, I think
my greatest strength
as an individual is not my
ability to take pictures,
but my ability to
connect with people.
I'm a really good people person.
I'm sociable, I'm happy,
I'm energetic, I animate,
I bring people
together, and I make
them believe that
they can do anything,
and then together we do stuff.
But I'm just a guy
pressing the button.
If I couldn't bring
these people together,
I wouldn't have
anything to work with.
And incidentally, yes, I take
pictures, technically speaking,
putting lights up,
all that stuff.
That's kind of secondary.
But my projects, my productions,
bringing these elements
together-- there's so
much pre-production
that comes into it.
I don't know, I guess it's the
excitement that just carries
through that vision, the idea.
Sharing with people and telling
them that anything is possible,
that they can do it, is
a huge part of what I do.
So I don't really know how
to answer your question "how
do you do it."
I just do it.
AUDIENCE: So apparently
from your photos,
it seems like there's a lot of
technical aspects associated
with them to be able to fully
realize the creativity that
is in your head.
How much of the
engineering background
that you had actually carried
through into the photography
world, or did you have to
basically start from scratch?
BEN VON WONG: You know, I
think every single experience
in your life is a
byproduct that contributes
to whatever you happen to do.
So the fact that
I traveled a lot
when I was younger-- I've been
in 13 different schools, three
different countries,
different languages,
means I can connect
to people very well.
The fact that I did 15
years of martial arts
means that I
understand movement.
I'm able to capture that.
I know what the peaks are.
I know how to communicate with
an athlete so I can connect.
And the fact that I had
training as an engineer
means I have a critical problem
solving analytical approach
to things.
But that's how I choose to
sell myself, because I mean,
I can just bullshit all
day long about what skills
and how they've contributed
to my background.
Engineering is
engineering-- I don't know.
I just downloaded
AutoCAD the other day
to design this rig that
we're going to be hanging off
the building, which was great.
I was so happy to learn that
something I did at school
is actually useful now.
But I can't really say that
it's something that's directly
contributed, but there
are definitely benefits,
just like everything
that you've learned,
all the experiences
in your life,
contribute to the final success.
I don't think you need to be an
engineer to be a photographer.
But it sure can't hurt.
But I'm sure a master
physician would
have just as much
to gain from it.
I guess the question
from now is,
how does it all come together?
How do you take all of
these pieces and everything?
How do they all come together?
How do they fall into place?
How do I make these
big productions?
I've talked about how I build
up to it, but how these all
come together?
And I think that it's all a
question about breaking it down
into smaller parts.
You have these stories
that are really
elaborate, that are
really large scale,
but at the end of the day,
if you break them down,
they're just like any
other photo shoot.
You have a location, you have
a model, you have your props,
you have the stylist,
you have your talent,
and all these little
pieces of the puzzle
working together
that you've brought
together so that
there's a story to tell.
And if you break these
down into little parts,
then they suddenly become
a lot more manageable,
because each one takes a certain
amount of work to figure out.
And you figure out
there's no there's
no huge magical
formula to figuring out
all of these things.
At the end of the day, really,
the solution is hard work.
So I just have a
couple stories on how
each one of these individual
elements were found.
So location, for example.
This was a shoot that
I did in a shipwreck
on the surface of
water in Vancouver.
And basically what
had happened was
I was going to fly over to
Vancouver and do a workshop.
But the workshop organizer was
so crappy that I flew in 8 days
before the shoot, and we didn't
have a place to shoot yet.
But he had sold tickets.
And I was like, what
are we going to do?
He's like, oh, we'll
just find a studio.
And I said, I don't
shoot in studios.
You can't do a workshop
with me in a studio.
We need to find a
really cool place.
So obviously he wasn't
going to be very helpful.
And I just started
hunting online.
I just went and stalked profiles
from other photographers that
were based out of Vancouver
that did crazier things.
So I reached out to a couple
of my friends that knew people,
and someone referred me to
this guy called Pete Jones.
And I was browsing his albums,
and I saw this shipwreck,
and I was like this is
where we need to shoot!
How do we shoot there?
So I wrote him a message,
presented my case,
that I was teaching,
really needed
help, I'm a
photographer, da da da.
And he's like, I can
give you the contact
information for the guy,
but just a word of warning,
he's kind of crazy.
I said, I don't care.
I want to shoot there.
So he gives me this number.
I call up the guy and I
tell him I want to shoot.
And he comes up with this
whole conspiracy theory
on why it's not OK to shoot
there because the government is
chasing after his land and some
illegal things and whatnot.
They'll shut them down.
And then he kept
talking, and then he
started rambling about
what the difference
between a Chinese person
was, a Korean person,
a Japanese person.
That conversation
lasted about an hour.
Didn't go anywhere.
But I didn't hang up the phone.
I just kept listening to him.
And then eventually
he said, well, I
can't let you shoot there,
but do you want to come visit?
And I said, yes, that's
exactly what I was waiting for.
So 8 o'clock the
next morning, we
drove down-- or actually
6 o'clock in the morning.
We drove down to meet him at
8 o'clock and say, oh, great.
Can we see the place?
So he took us for a
little tour, all the while
saying we couldn't shoot there.
And showed us how
amazing the place
was, this and that,
this and that.
And then at the end, we said,
well, why can't we shoot there?
And he shows us this sign by
the Agricultural Land Commission
and says, look at this thing.
They put a notice up.
They won't let us shoot.
I'm reading the sign,
and it doesn't really
say anything about
film or photo permits.
So there's a number at the end.
We call them up and say, hey,
we're at this guy's property.
Are we allowed to do
a shoot on the boat?
And they said, oh, yeah.
Actually the reason why
that sign is up there
is because he's declared that
these lands are being used
for farming purposes,
and he's got broken ships
on his property
instead of farming.
So it was just an excuse for a
tax break, and all this stuff.
I'm like, OK, so there's no
problem for shooting there,
right?
He's like, no, no, no.
It's not a problem.
I said, do you
think you can write
me an email officially
stating that we
have permission to shoot there?
He's like, yeah, no problem.
So he sends us an email.
We go back to the
dude and say, OK, we
have this piece of paper.
Can we shoot there?
And he says, nope, you can't.
I'm like, why?
Because the city
is not OK with it.
You have to go to the City Hall
to get permission from them.
I don't want any
trouble with the city.
I'm like OK.
We drove to City
Hall 15 minutes away.
We showed up at their doorstep,
explain the situation,
said hey, we want to
shoot at this shipwreck.
Can we shoot there?
This guy's crazy.
He says no.
They're like yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have no problem with him.
You can do whatever you want.
I'm like, can I
have it in writing?
I need a piece of
paper to show to him.
Right.
So he sends the piece of paper.
We go back.
Show it to him and say, OK, I
have all your pieces of paper.
Can we shoot here?
And he says, no but I don't
want any liability problems.
I don't want-- if someone
gets injured on set,
I'm going to be in trouble.
I said, OK, what if we prepare
all these liability insurance
forms?
And he's like, I
guess that could work.
And we went and got
all the liability.
We just printed some
samples off Google,
like these waiver forms, and
just signed all these papers--
and we had to fax them to him,
because he didn't have email--
and faxed all these
papers to him.
Called him up and said,
OK, can we shoot here?
And he said, well, I guess I
don't have a choice any more
It doesn't matter or anything.
[LAUGHTER]
So this took about two
days to sort through.
And then Wednesday--
so, three days
before the shoot
was going to happen,
I end up with permission finally
to shoot at the shipwreck.
And I just bring these photos
of this amazing shipwreck,
and I hit up a
clothing design store
and I said, hey, we have access
to this amazing shipwreck
for a weekend.
I'm going to be shooting.
I'm going to be teaching.
Would you lend us some clothing?
And then that's where
we found our designers.
Same thing.
We have these amazing costumes.
We have this amazing location.
Do you want to model for us?
And within one week, we
built the entire shoot.
So was it easy?
No, it was a pain in the butt.
It's a lot easier sometimes just
to trespass and sneak in there,
but this time I was
teaching, and it
needed to be official,
and all that stuff,
but that's how it came to be.
Right.
So nothing easy.
Hard work gets you there.
Sometimes it's a lot easier,
sometimes a lot harder.
Models.
How do you find models?
And models-- there's everything.
Facebook.
Your friends-- you can guilt
them into modeling for you.
You have Model Mayhem.
You have all these
different resources online
to find models.
And I think the one
thing that people
tend to overlook a little
bit is communities.
If you can think of a-- if
there's a group of people
that you're interested
in shooting,
there's probably a
community around it,
whether they dress up
as medieval characters,
as anime characters.
When I first started
out photography
and I wanted to do things
that were creative,
I went to the fetish community,
because they will do anything
and they have all the costumes,
all these different types,
and they love the attention.
So you ask any fetish
model whether they'll
model for you,
they're just like,
what do you want me to wear?
And they'll show up there with
these completely crazy things.
So if you find a community--
if there's something you like,
there'll be a community for it.
If you find one,
you find them all.
It's just like, you
find one photographer,
you find them all.
It's a really easy equation.
And some people get really
complicated about shoots.
And sometimes I
like to do things
that are a little
bit out of the box.
And this over here,
this shoot over here,
for example, every year
once a year in Montreal,
there's something called
a Victorian picnic.
And what it is is
just a group of people
that dress up in
Victorian costumes
show up at this picnic, and
they just have a picnic.
And incidentally, when cool
people with cool costume
show up at a picnic, well,
photographers show up.
I think there's usually more
photographers than picnic
people.
But at the end of the day,
what I did differently
from everybody else was
I reached out and I said,
hey, do you guys
think it would be OK
if I brought my mobile studio
and just bring some big lights
and everything and go crazy?
So instead of having the
semicircle of photographers
around the one single
model, I wanted
to do something a little
bit more elaborate.
They said, sure, no problem.
Just make sure you
ask for permission.
So I said great.
So went there.
I got there about
an hour earlier
with a group of my assistants.
Walked around, made
friends with people.
I think I was dressing up
in a corset at some point,
twirling around, just
making friends, spotting
all the people that I thought
would be interesting to shoot.
Because these people didn't
actually know each other,
but they're all dressed
in this similar fashion.
I just started
keeping an eye out
on all these different
individuals that
were interesting.
And after a while that people
had actually seen me there,
they knew that I was
nonthreatening, I suppose,
I decided to just bring all
these lights out and just set
up this huge studio just in the
middle where we happened to be.
And then we just source
all these people together
and then suddenly I
had this crazy set
that required zero preparation.
I just showed up there
and thought a little bit
differently.
And because I had all
the big fancy lights,
people were really interested
in what I was doing.
So the first one was
a little bit harder,
and then the rest just
kinda fell into place.
Props and accessories.
How do come across those?
And really, it's just about
the same thing as models,
except that, on top of that,
you might have different stores,
like prop stores,
centric stores.
I think at the end
of the day, you
have to think about what do
you have to offer them, right?
Why would they be interested
in lending you things?
That's if you want it for free--
if you want to pay for it,
then it's usually quite easy.
In my case, I don't like to
pay for things because I never
end up keeping them, but I
like to have really cool props
all the time.
So I'm sure you
guys have all wanted
to shoot with a
leopard or jaguar.
And I've always wanted to
shoot with these animals,
but, you know, getting
a trained jaguar just
costs thousands and
thousands of dollars.
So then I thought
to myself, well,
why don't we actually just
take a dead one-- taxidermied?
So Adobe was flying down
to do a documentary on me,
and they said that I could
shoot whatever I want,
and then they would document it.
So I said I better
make it exciting.
So this is off in
Toronto, where there
was a place called the
Scarborough Bluffs.
And I wanted to
do a photo shoot.
So I started looking around,
reaching out to my fan base,
saying, hey, do you
guys have any contacts
in the taxidermy industry?
And one guy just came
up and said, hey, I do.
I'm like, oh, great.
He had worked with
them in the past.
He gave me their
contact information.
I could have Googled
them-- they're
actually the biggest
taxidermy company in Canada.
And I wrote them an email.
They didn't really reply.
Wrote another
time, didn't reply.
I finally just ended up
calling them and explaining
that Adobe was going to do an
interview with me, that if they
would be so kind as to lend
me one of their pets, maybe
we could work something out.
We'll get the film crew
to come in and document
a little bit of
the surroundings.
Everyone can use it as
a nice visibility panel.
And they agreed.
They said as long as you have
$50,000 of prop insurance--
because apparently
one of these things
has a value of about
$30,000 or $40,000--
then we're more than
welcome to come and use it.
And so we did.
We ended up renting
a truck so that we
could fit this stinky thing in.
It's huge.
And we're six people
carrying a piece of plywood
carrying a Jaguar down the
beach to the exact place
that we needed it.
So how do you find super props?
Find the places that sell them.
Find a place that retail them.
If you can't afford
to buy it, give them
something that they
can use in return.
And talent-- talent.
You know, the fun thing
about talent-- and by talent,
I mean hair, makeup,
all that other stuff.
Body-painters.
You know, I think the key thing
is that these artists are also
just as driven by
great work as you are.
And the reason they would
want to work with you
is because you can represent
their work in the best way
possible.
And the thing is, if you
start doing the things
that you love and you start
creating content that you're
passionate about that other
people like to look at,
then you're going to attract the
people that like what you do,
too.
So it all works really,
really nicely together.
Very recently I did this photo
shoot with this body-painter.
This was actually done in LA
just a week, two weeks ago.
It was like 10 days ago.
And this guy's name
is Michael Rosner.
And I had seen his
work pass online
on one of those viral,
Buzzfeed type of websites.
And I saw it and I
was just blown away
by how amazingly
detailed and intricate
his body-painting work was.
And I really wanted to
meet up with him a year
and a half ago, when I
came to LA the first time.
And it just didn't happen.
I had added him on Facebook,
reached out to him,
shown him my work.
And this time around when
I came to LA, I said,
I'm working with you.
This is the one project
that I really want to do.
I helped fund the
designers to make
the costumes for the shoot,
specifically designed
to create something with
an underwater feel to it,
and got it all together.
But the only reason
these people wanted
to work with me
in the first place
is because I do
things-- I gravitate
towards what they want to do.
You have to always
think about what do you
have to offer in return?
In my case, my selling
point to this guy
who arguably is just as
successful as myself in the UV
world, if not more, I had
to come up with a product,
like a pitch, to
get him interested.
And my pitch was that I had
these brand-new fancy lights
from Broncolor that
they were going
to be lending me that output UV.
So I had UV flashes, which
meant that nobody else could
get these really, really crisp,
clean ultraviolet imagery,
because usually it
outputs so little light.
And it worked.
And it worked only because this
entire time, these last three
years, my portfolio
that's been building
has all been about these
extravagant, cool things that
are focused on new
technology, new gizmos, that
would potentially
Bring in more work
for him, which
is what he's interested in.
So you've all of this stuff--
location, models, props,
and talents.
How do you actually
coordinate all that?
How do you get people together?
How do you bring them together
to want to work with you?
And I have a couple tips that
have been really interesting.
The first is to make things
into group projects, not
your projects.
That means that, if the
project is about us,
it's a lot stronger.
If I go up to someone
and say, I want
you to do this for me,
that's usually on an I
want to hire you basis.
But if you say, let's
do something together--
what do you think, it
becomes a lot more communal.
People get a lot more
involved because they
have a stake in it.
It becomes about that
interaction between two people.
Explain to people how the
products are good for them.
So the difference
between saying,
hey guys-- say I was talking
Michael Rosner and I said, hey,
I really love your work.
It would look amazing
in my portfolio.
You absolutely have
to work with me.
It would be amazing.
That's significantly weaker
than me perusing his portfolio
and saying, hello, I've looked
at your ultraviolet shots,
and you know what?
I've noticed
there's a little bit
lack of detail in
your work, and that's
because you don't have the
right equipment for the job.
I happen to have sponsors
that are going to be giving me
$5,000 of equipment that will
now allow me to make your work
look better than it's ever
been presented before.
Do you want to work together
with me on something?
That's significantly stronger.
And it's the same exact pitch,
just phrased differently.
And I think that presenting
this, I'm thinking in this way,
and just on the general,
everyday basis of coming up
to people and talking to
them about how they're
going to benefit from
working with you,
is extremely powerful,
extremely fun.
Right.
Delegating things is also a
really interesting approach.
There's a bunch of benefits
of delegating work.
The first is, if
you delegate it,
you don't have to do it so much.
You have less to do.
The second is that, when you
delegate something to someone,
give them something to do,
they become more involved.
They're investing more
time into your projects.
In my case, for
example, I have a model
that I want to get involved into
my project a little bit more.
And we're looking for, I
don't know, a red dress.
And I say, hey, do you think
you can look into your wardrobe?
Do you have any red dresses
that you have there?
I'm kind of not too
sure which direction
I want to take this project.
If you can take some
selfies of yourself
in these different
dresses, I'd just
love to see what they look like.
And she sends them
back and like, oh,
I don't actually
like any of those.
Do you think you could go
to some stores that you like
and just maybe take some
shots of things you like?
Maybe create a Pinterest board
of dresses that you think
would be interesting.
We'll see what we
can come up with.
And then suddenly
this girl's already
put now like three hours,
whatever, into the shoot.
It's not just the
"yes, I'll come"
one-line text and Facebook.
So the day before
the photo shoot,
if she's gotten into an
argument with her boyfriend
at 2 in the morning, and she's
just crying all night long,
and woke up, and the shoot's
at 6 o'clock in the morning.
She wakes up, she's
hungover, and she
doesn't want to
come to your shoot,
well, she's already
invested a little bit more
time into the project.
She's invested a lot
more effort into it.
So they're even more
likely to show up,
because, once again, it's
not just your project.
It's their project, this
project that they care about,
it's a project that they
want to be involved in.
So delegating is super cool,
because not only does it
reduce your workload,
people get involved.
They feel like they
mean something.
They feel like they have a more
important stake in the project,
and it's just great
vibes all around.
Following up with things
is super important.
Why?
People are really, really busy.
People have things to do.
You know, if you
don't remind them
that they're supposed to be
doing something with you,
they're going to
forget about it,
and they're not going to be
part of the project anymore.
So you can't just get someone
interested three months down
the line, ignore them for
three months, and show up
and say, hey, why didn't
you show up to my project?
They completely forgot about it,
because you didn't follow up.
You didn't make sure that
they were still interested.
So I like to create
Facebook groups online.
I create these little groups,
these little communities.
We post pictures
up occasionally.
Every time there's
a new person that's
added to the project,
every time there's
a new update in
the development, I
share it just to keep
people interested,
to show them that things
are going forward.
Because these are large
projects that take time
to come together, people
need to be reminded
of what they're waiting
for along the way.
And then last but not least,
you have to take control.
So I talk a lot about
all these group projects.
I talk a lot about how
everybody is entitled
to pitching their
opinions, because these
are team projects, these
are team orientations.
But you still need
to be able to take
control of the final project.
You still need to be
able to take charge
and say, well, this
is what I want to do.
This is the vision.
Because there's only one person
at the end of the day who's
going to be shooting it.
There's only one
person that is going
to be editing it
and publishing it.
So that's probably going
to be the photographer.
So you have to know
what you want to do,
and you have to be
able to perform it.
Now, you have all
those four factors.
You know how to get them,
you know to get your talent,
you know how to
get your elements.
What could you
possibly be missing?
And that's technique.
And I think technique
is one of the things
that we, especially the geeky
engineering type of people
like myself, really
get caught up on.
And you don't want people--
like people don't look at images
and say, oh, wow.
That's an amazing three
point lighting set up!
Nobody thinks that way.
They see a story, and
then they appreciate it,
and then the technique that
you've used to create it
just becomes incidental.
Nobody actually cares
about the technique
that is used to
achieve the results.
So for example, this
image over here.
You look at it.
You don't go like, wow, that's
an amazing long exposure
shot combined with some flashes.
You don't see that, but
that's exactly what it was.
So in my case, what happened
was I bought some leaf filters.
That meant I could
drag the shutter.
I could bring some flashes
that the battery power strobes
that were a little bit
closer, and this is something
that I want to experiment with.
It was a new technique, but it
was built into a story line.
I knew that if I had a girl
crash on top of the waves
that look really good,
but it fits a story.
It's not for the effect.
The effect only serves
to enhance the story.
Right?
And so if you have all of the
stuff, you have your technique,
you have your models, and now
you want to tell your story,
it doesn't really
matter anymore what
elements you have and
ones you don't have,
because all the things that
you learn along the way
can be applied in any context.
This was a shoot that
I did in 24 hours
from the time the stylist
actually showed up to the rest,
to find the model,
design the costumes.
We found the location
the day of the shoot.
One hour before I got there,
I started doing some scouting.
The technique to light it.
All these things are
in the back burner,
because once you've mastered
how to make all of this work,
it's just a question about
recycling it and reapplying it
into whatever context
you need to do.
It doesn't matter anymore
what's easy and what's not.
And this, I suppose,
at the day, you
can summarize into being
the "epic formula."
And I can already hear people
complaining and saying, well,
my work's not epic.
It doesn't work
that way anyways.
And you know, what it really
is at the end of day, what
the difference is between the
epic an ordinary is something
that us as photographers
do every single day,
because you take what is
ordinary with your camera,
and because of the lens, the
perspective, the lighting,
the color toning,
all this stuff,
you make something that
is ordinary into something
that is epic.
That is what you do.
Am I running out of time?
I have 15 minutes?
All right.
I'll try to talk faster.
I can't talk faster.
I'm talking fast.
But as photographers,
that's exactly what we do.
We transform things
that are epic
and we make them into--
something that is ordinary
and make them into
something extraordinary.
And I have a couple
other examples
from other
photographers out there,
because I know that
you don't believe me.
And we can look at the work of
other photographers out there.
So Jason Lee.
He took photos of his
sons and daughter-- sorry,
his two daughters--
for a mother that
couldn't see them because
she was hospitalized,
and just came up with all these
creative ways of showcasing
his kids to his parents.
Jill Greenberg.
Taking kids-- not the
most exciting subject--
but putting them with
really edgy lighting,
different concept,
different storyline,
into something that
was very atypical,
telling something epic.
And then sometimes when
you do these projects,
they get picked up by people.
Seth Casteel.
Pet photography-- also not
the most exciting of things.
But because he came
up with the idea
of throwing a ball
into the water,
having these dogs come in just
looks completely different,
looks completely exciting.
Joey L. Going off to exotic
countries, traveling.
Going to the effort of
going there one month
before to meet the
locals, going back
another month after,
bringing [INAUDIBLE] strobes,
medium format cameras, all
of these different things
to come and shoot these images
in a way that hasn't been done
before, and then
coming back a month
after that to deliver full-size
prints to these locals who
have never had their
photo taken before.
Something that's
absolutely fantastical.
Martin Kilmas.
Product photography,
which is a boring subject.
But because he had taken
these subjects, put them
onto a high speed end trigger,
creating these really dynamic
action shots, it looks
really, really cool.
Quin Miller.
The T-Rex bride-- I'm sure all
of you guys have seen this.
Same.
He didn't come off with
the idea of saying,
I'm going to make something
that's going to go viral.
He came along with
this idea of saying,
I'm going to have
fun with what I do.
I'm going to do
what I love, and I'm
going to create something
interesting and something
exciting.
So anyone can do it.
There's not really an excuse.
Just a matter of perception.
No, we don't have
time for questions.
So I want to talk about
failure really quickly.
And failure I think is one
of those subjects that's
really important, because it's
something that a lot of people
have to go through--
or, everyone
has to go through it, really.
I have this quote over here that
I think is really interesting.
It's "I failed my way to
success" by Thomas Edison.
And I really believe
that's just how it works.
You can't wake up and
succeed at everything.
That's just not how
the world works.
I went to a conference
off in January,
and one of the presenters there
said this quote that I thought
was really amazing.
And he said, "The definition
of success is to suck less."
So if every day, you suck
less and less and less,
eventually you're going
to be successful, right?
And I have stories of a
failure here for you guys.
And there's these two failures,
which is Von Wong and fire.
For those of you
who know my work
or are relatively
familiar with it,
you'll know I shoot
a lot of fire work.
And this started off
with two failures.
So the first failure was when
I tried to light somebody
on fire.
So the idea came because we
have the Fstoppers competition,
and I told myself that, you know
what, even if I couldn't win,
at least I'd do
something so outrageous
that people would remember it.
And that was to light
someone on fire.
And I know what you
guys are all thinking--
that I roasted the guy alive
and that was the end of that.
But no, what
actually happened was
that this guy wouldn't burn.
It didn't really
matter what we did.
I don't know if it was because
we were shooting in December,
because we were stupid,
shooting in December,
it was super windy that
day, the fuel wasn't right.
Something just wasn't right.
And almost all the
fire that you see
is pretty much Photoshopped.
He just wouldn't burn.
It didn't really
matter what we did.
So it drove me crazy.
Cost us $350.
Turns out it's really expensive
to light a person on fire.
If ever you want to light
someone on fire, you'll know.
And $350 to light
this guy on fire.
So I complained to the
pyrotechnician and said,
you know what, you're
supposed to do it.
Didn't work out.
It's all your fault, na na na.
He said, OK, OK.
Why don't we do a shoot next
week, and I'll be the model?
And this time we'll
do like a stunt man
on fire, like I'll
go on a motorcycle,
light myself on fire, and you
can have some epic pictures.
And I said, great!
That sounds even better.
So moving on, that became
failure number two,
because failure number two,
we had the exact same problem,
unfortunately.
Even though we went in
a more sheltered place,
it was probably a
little bit colder
because we're still
in December in Canada.
And we try lighting
this guy on fire.
So the same thing--
the entire body's
supposed to be engulfed
in flames, and this time
he just would burn
in little patches.
It just wouldn't work out.
Didn't really matter.
So what did I do?
Photoshop.
There's not really
any way around it.
At the end of day, you gather
all these people around
to deliver a final
result, and this
was the closest
that we could get.
So the culmination
of these two failures
was, unfortunately,
a lot of popularity.
So these pictures,
these videos--
these behind-the-scenes
videos started
getting featured
all over the place,
and I think they were my most
viral videos at the time.
And I was like, why?
Why, out of all my photos
that are so much nicer,
why did these
failures get featured?
And the result of one of
these videos at the end
was this dude who
left a comment--
his name is Andre Dass.
He's a pyrotechnician
off in France.
And he said, your
photos are awesome,
but your fire work
kind of sucks.
And I was like, ha!
You're amazing.
You know what you're
talking about.
So I reached out to him
and I started stalking him.
I saw his work, and it was
some amazing fire stuff.
And I asked him if he wanted
to collaborate together,
and he said, when you come
to France, we'll talk.
And when I had my Europe project
to travel through Europe,
I reached out to him, and I
said I'd love to work with you.
And we ended up doing that.
And then that was the
time where we really
started working
together, and that's
where all my most iconic
fire work actually
started to take place.
This was when we finally managed
to find the best combination
of the guy who was able
to perform the effect,
and me who was able
to tell the story.
And we've done everything from
blending Tesla coils with fire
to actually going to
different countries
and performing
these different fire
pieces all over the place, which
was absolutely fantastical.
No time for questions.
[LAUGHTER]
So now the last
part is Photoshop.
And I think Photoshop is
always a really, really
interesting piece of the puzzle.
It's something that everybody
always wants to see.
And they make a
huge deal about it,
because they think that
everything that I do
is Photoshop, and they think
that if they could just
find out the secret
for what I do,
then they would be
able to do the same.
And I have some bad
news, and that's
that Photoshop is just
a tool like any other.
It's just one piece
of the puzzle.
It is the part of the puzzle
where you take the photo,
you bring it into the
computer, and you finalize it.
You make it look pretty.
You hide the trick
that made it work.
And so I have a bunch of
behind-the-scene images
of before and after.
This was a shoot that
I just talked to you
guys about shooting an
underwater shipwreck in Bali.
And this is the
before and after.
So you start off
with an image where--
if you guys shoot
underwater, you
know it desaturates everything,
gets rid of all the color,
so you end up with this really,
really bland color palette.
And you just clean
it up, getting rid
of different elements,
distracting elements.
You can transform an
image from being something
mediocre into something
absolutely phenomenal.
Here's the same shot
that I showed you
guys of the underwater
black lights
of the guys floating
on top of the water.
And we start off
with, once again,
an image that you get as
close to reality as possible.
Here you can notice
that even in the mouth,
we took these pieces of cloth
that we put onto their tongues
to give them a little
bit of definition,
but we didn't actually
manage to get it
all right in the right places.
But then just cleaning
it out, you still
go from the same image before
to cleaning out to after.
So you still start off
with something really cool,
and you make it better.
National Slovak Theatre
off in Slovakia.
We have this image.
The pose is interesting, the
lighting is pretty dynamic,
but, unfortunately,
you have one side
that's way better than
the other, the side that's
relatively dark, and the floor
needs a little bit of cleaning.
So what happens when you just
clean all these elements out?
Then the photo goes from
looking like something
that is pretty cool,
which looks like a photo,
to something that suddenly
becomes a little bit more
like an illustration.
On top of that, you
can give the guy
more biceps, which
is always good.
[LAUGHTER]
We take the same photo of
the shipwreck that I did.
And you'll notice--
I don't know,
you've already seen the after
picture, but you'll notice,
this one, the before
is a pretty picture,
but there's still things that
are really, really distracting.
The red of the lantern
immediately pops your eye,
because it's so red, it's
out of the color palette
of the rest of the image.
So it stands out.
It looks crappy.
Her hand.
Her hand is white.
We see the hand right
away, we ignore the face.
Why?
Because it's white.
It's in the center of the frame.
It's attracting a
lot of attention.
There's hair.
There's lines of water
streaming the wrong direction
across the hair.
Why?
Because I thought it
would be a good idea
to toss some water up.
It went the wrong direction.
So at the end of the
day, just getting
rid of all of
these details-- oh,
and making her
butt smaller-- are
things that really
make the shot go
from looking pretty to looking
almost like an illustration.
But there's nothing
really fancy about it.
You start with an image that's
as close to reality as possible
and make it better.
And of course, you have
images like this one, which
was shot at Disney
Concert Hall in LA,
where you're imposed the
restrictions of the location.
In this case, we weren't
allowed to have tripods.
So what we'd do?
I had this guy-- hefty
dude with a white shirt--
and he was my human soft box.
We put a flash instead
of his t-shirt,
and we have this
light just streaming
in from the side to light
up my main subjects.
Now because we had a
human soft box, well,
we couldn't actually
flag it off properly,
so you can see that
huge flare just bleeding
into the side of the image.
Doesn't actually work too well.
But then by cleaning
this all up,
by getting rid of
all the distractions,
by cleaning up that floor,
where all the different things,
by enhancing the colors
and the contrast,
your same image, which you've
gotten as close to as possible
in camera, now
looks even better.
And the part that I
spent the most time on
was just polishing
the floor, which
is the most boring thing ever.
It's like actually cleaning a
floor, except on a computer.
It sucks.
But the thing that
people always imagine
when they think
Photoshop is they
think images like this,
where you take, wow,
look this big, banging effect.
But the sad part is, when you
look at an image like this,
you know it's Photoshopped
right away, right?
Because you know
it's not possible.
So the illusion is lost.
And this was shot--
it's super easy to do.
It looks super impressive,
super easy to do.
No lighting.
We were in an abandoned
building-- big top, no roof,
light streaming in, having
guy jump off the ladder.
Took three shots--
one with a shirt,
one with a t-shirt,
one without a shirt--
this was the one I
retained-- and we just
tossed all these objects
up in different places,
and just kind of
pasted them into place.
Simple compositing.
There's nothing
really fancy about it.
It was a very, very simple edit.
I think it took less than
an hour to put together.
And I think, really,
at the end of the day,
images are supposed
to be enhanced.
Like Photoshop is really
that tool to enhance.
You try really hard to
get something close.
This is me breathing fire,
except that the magic is
a little bit lost,
because you see the torch,
you see the source of the flame.
You see where it's coming from,
which gets rid of the magic.
The fire is also not
big enough, and you
know, we like things
nice and big and poufy.
So just by taking that
same transform tool,
putting it in different
places, you can come
and you can make a
shot that looks really
good to start with
into something
that looks absolutely amazing.
And it's not complicated, it's
just about seeing the image
and knowing what to get rid of.
And of course,
removing the mistakes.
Things that you do-- you know,
in the middle of the shoots,
things that you
can't get rid of,
like your assistants shooting
from behind the pillar.
Really big pain in the butt.
You still have to be
able to edit them.
And you can enhance
your image, you
can make it better using
these simple tools.
And then like I said,
this is that shot
that I talked about
really, really
quickly about The
Agonists, where you really
try to get as close
as possible in camera,
because it means that you
have less work to do in post.
All these little
fancy effects that we
did-- all the sparks, all
the lighting, all that stuff
was time consuming, but
it wasn't complicated.
It was just about taking
faces from the image,
putting them into
the little screens,
taking these little sparks, and
stacking them up here and there
just to make the image
a lot more elaborate.
It doesn't matter what level
of complexity the image is.
It's the same tools
that you apply
over and over and over again.
Right?
So there's three
simple rules to follow.
And I think that if
you follow these rules,
and you apply it to any
level of photography,
it will really help
make them better.
And the three rules are number
one, removing distractions.
Number two, paying
attention to color,
and number three, darkening
things that are unimportant.
The first removing distractions
is very, very simple.
It's the idea of
getting rid of anything
that you don't need in an image.
So if you look at this
picture right here,
there are a bunch of elements
that are completely useless.
We have one, the bald spot
behind the grandmother's head.
We have two, the garbage bins.
They set you into the
present, because garbage bins
are a present thing.
We have that weird pole going
through the lampshade, which
you don't really
know what it is.
That tree line I also think
is completely useless,
because it doesn't
transport us anywhere new.
It doesn't tell us any
more where the location is,
doesn't make it
more exotic or not.
So getting rid of all
these distractions
and smoothing the
whole thing out
takes your image
of something that
is pretty into something
that is completely polished.
Because now, when you
look at the image,
your eye immediately goes
straight to the girl.
It follows the line down
to the couple watching,
and then it straps up, and
you notice where it is.
Because of the lamppost,
you know it's European.
You know there's
ballerinas, you know
there's people watching it.
It's almost like a show.
You complete the story
in your own head,
because now there are
no more distractions,
because you can automatically
just kind of piece
all these together.
This maybe looks a
little bit more posed.
Right?
Paying attention to color is
also really, really important.
I have this shot from the
Underwater Realm with no color
in.
And you can see, even though
all the characters are all
placed in the right
place, which is great,
it doesn't look magical.
It doesn't transport you.
But the minute you start
playing around with lighting,
you say, OK, well, the most
important part of this image
is what's happening
in the center.
So let's lighten it up.
Your shot's already a
little bit more interesting.
But now even though
it's interesting,
it still doesn't feel complete,
because the color's not there.
And because like I said earlier,
when you shoot underwater,
it eats all of the color out.
When you add the color
back in, then suddenly
your image becomes complete.
And it's just a question of
adding a little bit of oranges
in.
And the reason why it's
orange is because it gives you
that kind of sensation
of sunlight streaming in.
Right?
AUDIENCE: So part
of the failures
that I might think that
you probably have run into
is have you ever come
across moments of dry spells
in creativity,
where you just can't
form that story that
you're interested in?
BEN VON WONG: Yeah.
Definitely.
Yeah, definitely it's
one of those things that
happens, where you
aren't quite inspired,
and you don't really know what
you want to create anymore,
and you can't create anymore.
And I think that the solution,
when those times invariably
do come forward, is to just
keep doing the things that
make you happy, to force
things back to the present.
So it's normal as a
creative-- especially
you have these really high
ups and these low downs,
and it comes up and down--
that you don't really
know what you're trying to do.
But when you just do the things
that you enjoy-- for example,
in my case, that's meeting
new people, that's traveling,
that's going to new places--
even if I don't feel inspired,
and I just put myself
into these situations
where I'm doing the
things that I love to do,
then the inspiration
kind of gradually
follows along the way,
because it has to.
When you're doing the
things that you like,
even if you don't
really feel like them,
it's almost like
putting yourself
in a room with a
bunch of happy people.
You're eventually
going to start smiling.
So I think it's that
very simple idea.
But if you don't feel inspired,
and every day you just
stay at home and lock
yourself in a room
and go to sleep or watch
TV, then that inspiration
is probably going to be a lot
harder to come back to you.
Whereas if you're doing
the things that you enjoy,
it helps a little bit more.
That's cool?
All right.
I'm going to move forward
in my presentation
so that I can finish
it, and then we
can hang out and
ask questions, even
though you don't have a lot.
So darkening things that
are unimportant I think
is a very important thing.
And I have this image over
here, because you still
start with an image that,
at the end of the day,
looks pretty good.
But when you look at
the image, there's
still distractions
along on the way.
You don't really know how to
read the image, because you
have those really bright
patches in the front,
you have a lot of bright
patches coming in,
because the sun was streaming
in and we only had two lights.
But when you darken
things out and you
just even out the
lighting, then suddenly
that story becomes
a lot more apparent.
You control the
viewer experience
by simply controlling
the lighting.
And then suddenly by darkening
things that aren't important,
that you don't want
to call attention to,
it still sets the
tone and the mood
and the location
of the whole shoot
without affecting the
rest of the image.
And the reason why there's a
little start at the end of it
is because the only
time that wouldn't apply
is when it's a high key image.
And if you take an image
like this one, which
was shot at a
wedding seminar, we
have to get rid of
distractions, once again.
And you look at it,
and you're like OK,
it's really a mediocre
location, which it was.
How do you make it better?
Well, if you clean
up all the areas
and you make things
brighter, that same image
can go from looking very mundane
into looking really, really
clean.
Even if you look at this image,
well, I kind of screwed up
because I forgot to
brighten the reflection
on the bottom, the reflection on
the tiles, but it still works.
It's still cleaned up the
image, because now, there's
nothing else to distract you.
You just see front and
center the main model,
because all the other
stuff has been blown away.
So those are the three
simple rules to follow.
And the good news about
these three simple rules
is that they work in
just about any context.
So we have this photo
over here, which
is of the medieval shoot, which,
incidentally, is a photo that I
really dislike, because it
just took hours of Photoshop
to fix up.
The original image
actually looked
like this, which
is a complete mess.
You look at it, you have
no idea what's going on.
It looks like a tavern brawl.
And the reason is because
the lighting wasn't done.
I thought that if I put one
light up over to the left
and I put another light
up over to the right,
I would kind of create this nice
cross-lighting set up, which
would create a spotlight
effect on the characters
in the center, and then if I
popped a whole bunch of strobes
in the background, then it
would kind of rim the existing
characters and it
would look really cool.
I was completely wrong.
But I had 50 people
waiting after me to model
and wondering why
it was taking me
so long to press my button on my
camera while they were posing.
So at the end of the day, I
just had to take the shot,
and I told myself
I'd fix it in post.
And I originally
knew that I was going
to add these two
jumping characters.
So this is kind of the shot
that I started off with.
You can see it's absolutely
illegible, impossible to read.
You have no idea
what's going on.
So in applying those same
rules into this image, which
is desaturating and
darkening the things that
aren't important,
you can already
notice how big of a
difference that makes just
by getting rid of all those
really bright spots that
served no purpose.
The image suddenly starts to
stand out at the right place.
We know that the
center of the image
is the most important part.
The characters are
the most important.
We fill up all the holes
from a composition standpoint
to make sure that all
the characters are
in the right place
at the right time,
and then you suddenly
have this nice spiral
that is framing the
center of our image.
From there we have light,
contrast, and colors.
So what I was saying about
making the center just
a little bit brighter to draw
a little bit more attention
into the middle was going to
be really, really critical
to making the shot look
a little bit better.
And then I reached
this point where I just
didn't know what to do
anymore, because I was like,
OK, well I got pretty far.
It's looking pretty good, but
it still looks like a mess.
I started to think
about what I could
do to make it at least
stand out a little bit more.
And I figured that, what
do they do in video games?
Well, all the
characters are glowing,
so why don't I just
make them glow?
So I made all the
characters glow.
And now suddenly it looks like
a completely fantastical scene.
It doesn't make perfect sense
from a completely physical
standpoint, but it does actually
look like a legible image.
You can kind of understand
what is going on,
and it's not too bad.
And unfortunately,
what this means
is that you end up with
a bazillion layers,
bazillion hours of work.
So, 40 hours of work.
And you'll notice that in the
beginning of my presentation
where I was talking about
why I love photography,
at no point did I say sitting
in front of my computer
alone for 40 hours.
So that is one of
the reasons why
I love to just get out
there and do things
as much as possible in camera,
so I don't need to end up
in this situation over here.
So in conclusion,
what I'm trying to say
is that photography is
really about these splits.
You have 33% that's really
about the pre-production,
about getting all the
elements right beforehand,
so that when you do your
shoot, which is the next 33%,
you can actually do
a good job, apply
all the technical
knowledge you have.
And then the last 33% is
really the post-production side
of things, where you sit down
and you fix, you iron things
out, and you complete the job.
And now the good news
is you don't really
need to be great at
all the three above.
If you suck at
pre-production, well,
you can be a really
great photographer
and compensate for it, or be
really great at post-production
if you suck at shooting
and pre-production.
You can compensate for
all of these things.
So it's just one
of these balances,
and you need to figure out
which point do you stand?
What is the balance
that you want to be?
So in conclusion, "Choose
a job that you love,
and you'll never have to
work a day in your life."
Confucius.
That is it.
The end.
[APPLAUSE]